[Music]
in kids and occult news that will matter
that yes called Pokemon in its
collection hey there's nothing wrong
post my okgo escort you see look at that
no pokemons fun I like a Pokemon good
Fred watch you drank the kool-aid Julia
I did I ate the cereal because Bakuman
cereal and I was very excited and
wanting to eat it yeah submitted by
Taylor loves the JK lady hey I stopped
being a pervert Taylor Taylor could be a
girl yeah then why's you talk to them
all sexual oh those are [ __ ] vagina
MEP Gio stopping sexual Oh human woman
haters find some little rascals I don't
know why people should just anyways this
little rascal this multicultural geo
survivors of a notorious cult reveal
their story behind this brutal regime
brutal
what's this cult called this cult was
called the Boy Scouts no family oh
that's a great day sink
that's a great name it used to be called
or it's also called the great white
brotherhood I like that one like shirt
yeah the great white turtles let me
guess they're all bald they wore Doc
Martens steel-toe Stockman with a
leather jackets and a jeans that they
roll up and they put up to here and then
they put suspenders on and had a bomber
jacket yeah
and they had the tattoos that kind of
looks like the Buddhist symbol for peace
and prosperity but they flip it the
other way around and then they listen to
me they look bad close but no very close
guys yeah so this this cult was a really
huge thing this happened in Australia
this started off in the mid 60's by this
glamorous yoga teacher she would teach
to the wealthy always those yoga
practitioners [ __ ] Yogi's oh it's
bending over
name is a Anne Hamilton burn so when she
was under the influence of LSD she had
this vision that everyone has a vision
that she had to collect children whole
cause one day World War three is going
to cause most of the world to most of
the human race to die oh my god imagine
she's right I mean she was just too
early it's gonna happen but she's just
too early probably already died 60 she
still alive oh damn she's 96 years old
oh should plug she don't never know God
did this she's on the verge yes uh hello
lead roses cult no so she still doing
yoga that's a good track in our bonus
[ __ ] hey that's the secret to longevity
[ __ ] run a cult and do yoga hmm
downward dog and her [ __ ] ditches
fall out so she began to create her cult
after having this vision and she had she
was able to convince people that she was
the reincarnation of Jesus Christ
because she's a girl
basic she's also mixing two religions
together every [ __ ] kool-aid years
because Jesus as she mix up including
UFOs if she would even include UFOs or
nah you mean Scientology and it's under
someone I'm somebody come up with some
cult [ __ ] it's always the same thing
like a little bit of Egyptian a little
bit of UFO a little bit of Jesus it's
the same thing maybe there's some truth
to it no it's because about that they
just unoriginal they copy each other the
Spaghetti Monster I like that guy they
just been going to the same cult
seminars I mean you were cult seminar so
they can come with more original ideas
yeah I read about one where this teen
escapes like this sex cult oh and like I
think his family was the one that was
running the whole cult - and I want to
be a part of a sex cult
no you don't do human he's like in his
interview he lays dude yeah in his
interview who say that he was
traumatized because he had to like have
sex with another family member of his
own little mom right
different ones those either um that's
wrong that's like empirical niece or
cousin I'm not sure but all I know is I
found into a [ __ ] cousin
I might have to [ __ ] that and then I
probably when he was like a baby or when
he was young like Dobby made though like
days now and I like Oh as their
breathing him like they'll start like
Jackson's mom that's [ __ ] cool no
it's not it's horrible
you're doing it against them will and
what surprised me was that I was reading
this and I think like a 7py case with
our [ __ ] we don't have a team magazine
I don't know the long time ago [ __ ]
it was Huskers at the editors table and
Seventeen magazine
this is like years ago when I was like
sitting in the waiting room for my
dentist's appointment
oh you're altered reading highlights and
[ __ ] and in their [ __ ] father I was
taking a quiz on what horse coupon was
or like what my horse was going to tell
me and then also nurses article like
about just do it escaping a cult I'm
like oh that's interesting and then they
had that like wow this is weird to have
this at a teen magazine uh in a movie it
maybe was yeah you probably filled in
the blanks with the yeah the jacking
often alone oh they slightly oh my god I
know the way your mind were your JK bro
come on honestly go that doesn't make me
feel like oh my god the horrors it's
like it's in control not picturing like
three french maids like bathing you
seductively no these had no scheme use
ik and then there's lighter and lunch
lady bathing you in jacking you off
instead
yeah any hand but mine would be kind of
cool if I was 13 she does construction
on the side she's got a lot of calluses
still not my head sure dude anyways back
to end got low so when she started her
cult she said she was a yoga teacher to
a lot of rich people she was able to
recruit a lot of doctors lawyers nurses
architects scientists so a lot of like
wealthy well-off like intelligent people
were able to like be persuaded by this
girl cuz they're stupid not a bunch of
hippies they're [ __ ] smart here but
they suck at being people hmm cults
never recruit comedians
they never though I got the best group
of comedians and I'm going to take
advantage of them the other two cynical
there might be some comedians in the
scientology well i guess is that a cult
who i think what that means is comedians
are too smart for that [ __ ] we could
smell [ __ ] a mile away yeah go get a
doctor that's true
doctors are stupid as [ __ ] dude they
always get [ __ ] up it's not gonna
brainwash the comedian yeah
watch you're gonna go to your doctor
that watches the shows avec oh looks
like you got something in you bump too
stupid to tell ya oh let me rephrase
that they're people stupid Oh comedians
are the philosophers of the world I hope
you know ya comedians are people smart
but [ __ ] dumb and everything else in
life can't do a damn thing
oh I kind of read about make you laugh
yep because I make observations that you
can't with my social are you looking
directly at me
[ __ ] you I didn't know I was even
looking at you you just can't take your
eyes up yeah all right look what stop
trying to change the subject we're
talking about a call here this is
serious
go on Tim you [ __ ] interrupter King
and so this lady she had at one point
500 people following her she had pretty
big [ __ ] genius
charismatic yeah she also collected 10%
of her followers income I was able to
have a huge massive fortune because
they're all doctors and [ __ ] yeah
exactly
and so um their communion should have
been broke yes that's why they don't you
should have been happy though yeah I
cults are all about making money yeah I
didn't make money off since communities
that's true and it's hard to brainwash
comedian damn she's a [ __ ] genius and
so I hate her she says it why why why do
somebody because it's a skill that Joe
doesn't have
he does he's got your mommy yeah but
it's not a cult
it's behind of it and I don't get any
money from it uh it's a cult it's not a
cult you know what it is it's a
collective it's a it's a party
screeching you know what this is
this [ __ ] is a fraud I'm not a fraud
how do you know she probably really
believes in herself I don't believe in
yourself if you need to collect children
just collect them why I got a collect
money that's not a part of your plan
you took Ella to be and you said I need
to collect children and [ __ ] save the
earth actually want it but weirdoes
taking money from doctors and
businessmen come into play if the world
has ended you're going to need a lot of
money to rebuild the world money's not
even going to work if it won't ended
that's true you just need a stockpile on
[ __ ] astronaut food and water seeds
the children are the sea yeah exactly
so she was able to obtain 14 children
and that's it yeah just five other
people Shirley had 40 children yeah
that's all you need okay yeah so she was
able to obtain all these kids and like
really shady ways because she had
connections with lawyers and doctors and
things like that and it was either that
or she she received these kids because
people in the cult actually gave them
their kids that's crazy
yeah so Jen she had this a secluded
lakeside property with a school for her
children as she called up top and so
throughout all the viewers - they would
have groomed these kids like she made
them cut their hair into like identical
bobs they would wear identical outfits
and they were told to behave as siblings
and so they were denied access to the
entire outside world what a crazy
experiment yeah and so like the street
they would be punished with wild
outbursts of violent anger and
starvation Oh Massa the children never
knew how to escape their punishments
because the rules would constantly
change
and they could not say that they were
unhappy and they always have to be
compliant in Thailand and she would drug
these kids with LSD yeah oh that's crazy
yeah she like really [ __ ] up these
kids like crazy and they were so they
were frequently dosed with LSD and that
when they reached adolescence they were
forced to undergo an initiation a
process involving more LSD so like they
were just awesome are they all alive now
still I'm not sure about everyone but I
do know that survivors they're retelling
their story because there's a
documentary in the works and also a book
oh my god we're getting like an insight
of like how these people actually live
like the survivors just [ __ ] crazy so
they're saying is that work when there
were workmen that went to that property
when you're in like the least 1970s
just a typical electricity lines and so
they had to be there for a couple weeks
and so she told these children to act
like they were mentally disabled so the
so then the workmen could think that
that's like a special school so they
wouldn't have any suspicion so it wasn't
until 1987 when one of the children her
name is Sarah
she got disowned by the house for some
reason like they had it's dispute so she
got just on from the house jump was they
let her out like that I know that's not
singing - I'm like a pretty girl always
secrets yeah so then she once she got
out she went to the police and she told
them about everything that she knew it
was wrong we think fussing with them
sexually though that they don't report
that I mean they've already been [ __ ]
up mentally tortured drugged I know I
don't think it's possible yeah
whether or not it was sexually it
doesn't make it worse or that or like
that it's just that he was so [ __ ] me
yeah super [ __ ] is like they would
punish the way she would punish these
children - is that she would leave them
in dark room with Ellis like tripping on
LSD and that they would only they would
only get visited by either N or one of
the psychiatrist from the group and
that's
no access to adults other than those two
well other than like the adults like
working to keep everything together
people will recall adult was she
planning like in the future after the
world ends and these kids are all [ __ ]
up like were they going to lead the
world with LSD minds yeah what she said
they say that they they were being
groomed to like repopulate the world at
one point and that they would need to
teach the world like how the world used
to be on one point but they don't even
know how the world is to be exactly this
is a man and this is some of the kids
that she had that look creepy look at
their hair the Aryan Brotherhood and she
had them do like yoga and things like
that so Oh feels it looks like it's from
my cool movie so I don't I'm not sure
where they come I mean they look like
they're having a fun time say Harry
Truman yeah they have oh yeah had to say
they were happy damn I wonder how their
brain develops look going to children of
the corn or something it looks kind of
scary yeah how did how did your brain
how would your brain develop if you do
it before adolescence and you're like
it's all like wired weird yeah a lot of
these survivors are just saying I have
to live with with it and still live with
all of this and I was trying to look
into like how did she just get away with
it because you 96 years old right now
she's living with dementia in a nursing
home and she still has like her huge
fortune like just waiting there until
she dies for someone else to come over
and take over
no one press charges right so the cult
is still existing well they're saying
that there's like a small number of
people that are still worship her and
that still try to keep up there their
headquarters but they're the copters
being that is probably no more than 30
or 40 people that's still a lot of
people that's masked after Sarah
in 1987 went to the police that's when
the police went to the home and raided
everything they took the kids away and
so after the raid and
then they fled the country for about six
years and then there was an
investigation involving police in
Australia the UK in the US which
ultimately resulted in their arrest in
1993 and they got arrested by the FBI in
New York and so they were extradited to
Australia and they were charged with
conspiracy to defraud and to commit
perjury by falsely registering the first
of three unrelated children as their own
triplet that's what they got charged
with yeah
they ended up getting they ended up
pleading guilty to the lesser charge of
making a false equation and they were
only fined $5,000 each what past that I
don't know like what well fake it all
that running and they only got a five or
five thousand what the [ __ ] so there's
just a lot of like tiny little like
personal cases that the show was
involved with but nothing grand like for
the entire like cult thing that I could
find she's going to get in trouble with
the National yoga Association I sure
hope so also
she should lose our yoga badge of honor
yeah shouldn't be teaching you anymore
hey guys thanks for watching on this
episode if you want to submit your own
articles check out the link in the
description box below and if you want to
see more videos check them out right
over here
[Music]